wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
woher stammt ist familie was glaubt ihr
wer möchte es versuchen
ich glaube dass ios deutschland kommt ja
und nein
der ort aus dem meine familie kommt
liegt heute in polen
aber als meine eltern dort lebten lag er
noch in deutschland
wer kann mir sagen wann das war das war
bestimmt vom zweiten weltkrieg ganz
genau und als deutschland den krieg
verloren hat mussten meine eltern unsere
heimat verlassen
da war ich noch nicht geboren gab es
damals genauso viele flüchtlinge wie
heute sogar mehr und die menschen kamen
in ein land in dem sehr viel kaputt war
immerhin konnten sie die sprache
verstehen denn sie haben auch zu hause
deutsch gesprochen das war sicher ein
großer vorteil da hattest deine familie
nicht so leicht wo ist ihre heimat hier
oder der ort aus dem ihre familie stammt
das kleine dorf aus dem meine familie
kommt ist auch ein teil von mir meine
mutter hat mir viele geschichten aus
ihrer jugend und kindheit dort erzählt
ich bin mit meinen eltern noch ein paar
mal dagewesen aber meine heimat ist hier
in deutschland